[Música]
economía nuevamente segundo bloque
económico de nuestra mañana y último por
esta semana daniela porque es viernes
eso es que este los ministros de
economía del g20 se reúnen en phillip y
la sal y que están hablando en este
momento pues estos líderes financieros
de las principales 20 economías se
reúnen en bali para abordar la crisis de
inseguridad alimentaria a corto plazo
exhar se exacerbada por la guerra de
rusia en ucrania eeuu por ejemplo pide a
los demás gobiernos evitar las
restricciones a la exportación y también
el almacenamiento de alimentos así como
enfocarse en medidas de apoyo fiscal en
lugar de adoptar subsidios generales que
son costosos y regresivos
gooding las acciones de putin que
incluyen la destrucción de instalaciones
agrícolas el robo de granos y equipos
agrícolas así como el bloqueo efectivo
de los puertos del mar negro se
convierten en el uso de alimentos como
arma de guerra
los más afectados directamente son los
hogares más pobres en los países más
pobres
se prevé que la situación en 2022 se
deteriore aún más y esto no es una buena
noticia para nosotros la pandemia de
kobe 19 no resuelta así como la guerra
que se desarrolla en ucrania
probablemente exacerben la ya grave
situación de inseguridad alimentaria
aguda que todos estamos viendo además de
eso una inminente crisis de
fertilizantes también tiene el potencial
de extender aún más la crisis
alimentaria incluso hasta más allá de
raúl usted se acuerda que en la pasada
reunión de cancilleres o boicot a los
funcionarios de rusia esta vez no lo
había pues es como lo dijo como lo dijo
lo que lo dije anteriormente han y
también pues la mejor manera de
solucionar algo es hablando adentrándose
en una mesa la diplomacia y en eeuu
soplan soplan vientos de recesión
nosotros ya lo hablé avanzamos acá con
nuestro invitado al día esta semana
claro todos sabemos que el
comportamiento de las principales
entidades financieras es un muy buen
termómetro para medir cómo les está
yendo la economía en general y al cierre
del primer semestre el resultado no es
alentador en eeuu las ganancias de las
principales instituciones
país cayeron en los primeros seis meses
y con más fuerza en el segundo trimestre
por ejemplo jaypee morgan que es el más
grande y wells fargo que es el tercero
las redujeron más del 30% entre enero y
junio y morgan stanley lo hizo en 19%
esta es una lista que se va a
complementar más tarde con bank of
america y citigroup porque se han visto
afectado a los bancos mire una
explicación rapidez y mal los
inversionistas están muy preocupados de
que la reserva federal ponga la economía
estadounidense en recesión a través del
aumento de tasas para combatir la
inflación y una recesión significaría
que los estadounidenses perderían sus
trabajos y probablemente comenzarían a
retirarse de sus préstamos o mejor no
pagarlos en el corto plazo sin embargo
pues esos temores también se han
compensado con los mejores ingresos que
tienen los bancos gracias a las tasas de
interés más altas es un gana-gana
siempre así están y en china también las
cosas no están tan bien económicamente
porque el gobierno reveló este viernes
datos económicos poco alentadores el
producto interno bruto de la segunda
economía más grande del mundo se
desaceleró al cero 4% en el segundo
trimestre de este año comparado con el
mismo periodo del año pasado este es un
resultado mucho más bajo que el 48 por
ciento que había crecido en el trimestre
anterior esto podría representar un gran
impacto para el resto del mundo ya que
estamos hablando del mayor consumidor
global de materias primas y el riesgo de
estanflación en la economía mundial está
aumentando las políticas de las
principales economías tienden a ser más
estrictas y las inestabilidades e
incertidumbres externas se suman
obviamente y en el plano interno el
impacto de la pandemia es persistente la
reducción de la demanda se entrelaza con
la interrupción de la oferta por lo que
aún no se han consolidado las bases para
una recuperación sostenible y constante
de la economía
raúl él hablaba de estanflación no se me
asuste le voy a explicar que es es
cuando en un países se juntan dos malos
datos económicos o dos malos
comportamientos que son el estancamiento
y la alta inflación existen bolsillos
están financiados y danielle indicadores
estos malos datos de china movieron las
bolsas asiáticas que cerraron mix con
grandes pérdidas en chancay las bolsas
europeas mientras tanto se comportan al
alza con alemania ganando casi un 2% y
españa y londres más del 1 por ciento
danny como siempre gracias o por toda la
información económica económica por
supuesto el lunes con más economía usted
vio las imágenes de que lanzó este
reciente de telescopio james webb
puestos son hermosos bueno lo invito a
que se quede porque eso vamos a hablar
en nuestro reportaje